what's going out reject nation it's Greg
Alba Kia and it's John Humphrey over
here so we got something summer by a few
people the tees for the mother trailer
John and I in general aren't big fans of
trailers for trailers but a lot of
people said this is still worth checking
out it's 30 seconds long just give you
guys a heads up over at our patreon
we're removing in our live streams over
to our patreon for just the one dollar
pledge for this week's live stream what
we wanted to do is we're going on the
movie trivia Schmoe damn we got to film
an episode and so to help us prepare
we've asked everyone on patreon to just
gather up your questions and then during
the livestream you can ask John onto
questions it's this Thursday help us
prepare for the show in fact darren
aronofsky directed this oh boy
it's been a while since I've seen him
around we're going to win the showdown I
love Aronofsky's war Noah Mulholland
Drive The Thin Red Line yeah you know
King's Cup Knight of cups jennifer
lawrence's end s Cosco running role in
the room a buddhist god what they told
me I could find a room here he thought
we were to bed I'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
whoa hook Trey Luthor's it's way better
than those trailers for upcoming
trailers then you get like those
15-second teases you get three shots in
the side yeah yeah that's way better
than that because it seems like they
composed like they took audio from
throughout the movie they can post it
over this one shot and which is cool
because earner an auskey I love that he
does a lot of those types of one shots
their hand he'll they kind of just
follow you around they could start from
the throw and then go from behind very
naturalistic and very boyars exactly and
what we know from the IMDB plot it's one
of those domestic thrillers about you
welcome strangers into your home and
then everything goes wrong they got a
different plan and in terms of Aaron
obviously exploring mood intention he
fluctuates a lot between what he's
working on and what he does and my
favorite kind of films all from darren
aronofsky are more of these kinds of
movies you know black swan requiem for a
dream as much as I somewhat enjoy the
fountain I did enjoy the movie Noah
actually a lot this is more of his
territory that I like him to be in for
him to be teaming up with Jennifer
Lawrence in a film like this because I
think Jennifer Lawrence still kills it
in film when she works with directors
like this for films on this scale right
as well she does huge Hollywood
blockbuster films I feel like this is
the types of films that made her have
such a portion career where she's one of
the Oscars from and everything when you
do those sweet spot movies they're like
they're still kind of thrilling and
they're not not like genre the same way
you think about like big genre
blockbusters but they're like kind of
high-concept darren aronofsky has a very
you know distinct style and you know his
characters are often people like his
movies often sent around people who are
letting their obsessions and their
compulsion asteroid them just as a
teaser alone this is definitely full of
mood and dread and actually quite light
combination of this jarring weird like
we said voyeuristic like you're just
watching Jennifer Lawrence kind of pace
around her house while you've got this
Audie
playing that is yeah hinting into what
succumb to the fact that we can't see it
and we're in this for some reason very
sparse arid empty house and you open the
door nobody now just as the team's alone
it's pretty cool well what I get from it
is everything you're hearing all the
audio that's playing is all coming from
the fact that she made a choice to open
that door and let these strangers in her
home and that's I think it's a clever
tease because like you or the nightmare
that's going to come all from this
decision she makes in this scene if you
watch his movies they're normally not
categorized as horror yet a lot of them
have moments of serious suspense and
just sometimes flat-out terrifying
especially movies like Black Swan right
and even requiem for a dream I know the
movie pie that you did is considered by
many to you know be a horror movie as
well this one I see advertised
everywhere at least I've seen from like
articles on you know sites like a
lighter say Darren Aronofsky's horror
movie
and so I'm excited for him to see to do
this like domestic they're something
that I be even simpler you know I like
his films I find a complexity and
something that might be perceived as not
so complex
yeah I believe this was his original
concept for the Wolverine before James
mangle took over yeah yeah looks like
looks just like now just imagine Hugh
Jackman wandering around a house alone
oh geez furniture - turns out like
Hobson Mike ran well subscribe to
Varitek click the knob accustomed but
test Jennifer on Twitter and Instagram
and a trio yeah
we often Anthony Kiedis impressions over
there ah boring thing the outter over
Hilary